your dad stole my parents life savings
my college fund everything your family
didn't deserve what happened to them
Zach but that's just the way the cookie
crumbled working three jobs is never a
fun time but in some twisted way you owe
a special thank you to Michael Jalali if
he hadn't fled the country with your
family's money you never would have met
and fallen in love with his daughter Ava
talk about a silver lining this is all
good for both of us
Zach fortune in Ava Jalali come from two
very different worlds but they're more
alike than they like to admit we're so
happy these two put their differences
aside and followed their hearts they are
literally made for each other keep
watching to find out why Ava and Zach
are endgame enemies first friends second
Haven Zach first met in the episode Lost
and Found and for Zach it's pretty much
hate at first sight he immediately gives
Ava the cold shoulder when she asks him
for help during the campus fashion show
he tells Ava so take a number and wait
your turn which totally catches her
off-guard but it isn't until much later
that Ava discovers by Zach hates her as
it turns out Zach's family invested all
of their savings in to Ava's father's
company and he fled the country after
secretly embezzling millions of dollars
as a result Zach's family lost
everything including his college fund
any more questions but despite all this
Zach eventually warms up to Ava and a
peculiar friendship is formed friends
second lovers third some people jump
right into relationship and others
become friends before making things
official we love how Ava and Zach went
from being enemies to friends to lovers
after losing NOLA Ava was completely
heartbroken and there was a lot more on
her mind than finding herself a new
boyfriend well he reminded me of someone
I lost but Ava and Zach's bond was too
powerful to ignore and slowly but surely
Ava started to heal both Zach and Ava
were going through a rough patch before
they met but becoming friends and
falling in love helps them get out of
the dark this adorable couple lifts each
other off instead of tearing each other
down thank you which is why they are
couple goals the puzzle assignment in
the episode titled dead weak Ava and
Zach reluctantly pair up together for a
school assignment and there's trouble in
paradise
Ava tries to get closer to Zach but he
ends up
telling her of course you take the easy
way out just like your dad
despite beated odds with each other Zack
and Eva pull through and end up scoring
a perfect score on their paper they
received the highest score ever recorded
in their history class proving that they
work well together surprisingly Ava and
Zack score proves that they're more
alike than twins who can read each
other's minds I swear they used mind
tricks to finish each other sentences if
this doesn't prove that they're made for
each other we don't know what will
they're different yet the same it's
totally normal for couples to have
different likes and dislikes but when it
comes to Ava and Zack they're
practically worlds apart ava is a cat
person and Zack is a dog person but
instead of debating which animal is
better
Zack chooses to pretend he likes cats I
don't want to start back at square one
with you so I'm just gonna lie this
moment was so adorable and we still
can't get over it the way Zack looks at
Ava says it all their team's Ava for the
win and we're rooting for them Zack
makes Ava laugh so hard she snorts is
there anything cuter than a person who
snorts when they laugh yeah we didn't
think so despite looking like she has
her life together
Ava is falling apart the only person who
ever made Ava laugh to the point of
snorting was her ex-boyfriend Nolan
Hotchkiss movie laugh - Lily
so when Zach succeeds at making Ava's
snort it's a pretty big deal nice laugh
- Molly finding someone who can make you
laugh and be your true self with is what
falling in love is all about and it's
clear that Zach and Ava have humor in
the bag they know the meaning of hard
work
Ava grew up super privileged but that
didn't stop her from becoming a hard
worker
Ava's parents fled the country to avoid
a major scandal leaving Ava to fend for
herself instead of crumbling under
pressure
Avis started her own YouTube channel to
pay for her education ava is super smart
and resourceful and she knows the
meaning of hard work I will work to pay
my way and well the same can be said
about Zach who works three jobs having a
good work ethic and being able to work
together proves just how compatible
these two really are they support each
other in season 1 episode 9 Eva and Zach
attend the school gala
however Zach is working as a server
while Ava is there
a guest Ava's talking to a very
influential person when she notices li
redmond in the crowd she cuts her
conversation short to go and convince
Zack to speak with mrs. Redmund Ava
encourages Zack to be himself telling
him to take advantage of the moment
don't lie sir sorry she offers to cover
for him and tells him how much she
believes in him this moment was so sweet
and it proved just how much Ava
truly cares for Zack Zack was
overwhelmed by her actions which led to
him kissing Ava for the very first time
thanks to Ava's sacrifice Zack was able
to secure the summer exhibition in New
York couples who support each other stay
together
which is why fans everywhere are
shipping diva diva for the win so do you
think Ava and Zack are into game or will
Ava's secrets drive a wedge between the
new happy couple before you go tell us
abou things ava is the real OTP or if
ava is better off with someone else
sound off in the comments and that's a
wrap hit that subscribe button and give
this video a big thumbs up
[Music]